the Joe Rogan experience same question
to you how do you fix this so on the
rile start with the riots because I
think my view is clear reestablish
law-and-order
I agree you use that opportunity to
seize upon again the 50-plus one things
what do we all learn through this
pandemic it's pretty stupid that our
corporate elites and our political
elites allowed many of our most critical
jobs in industries in order to go over
to China
that's an empirically stupid thing yes
reassuring American supply chains makes
us safer in the long run both from a you
know and economic respect from national
security perspective health perspective
etc like the China thing is like a 90/10
issue and right now I want to make sure
I call this out which is that there are
elements in the White House more
corporate friendly ones who are trying
to quash a by American order that was
put forward you know within the Trump
administration that doesn't even call
from mandatory like on shoring of
medical supply chains but just like
wants to use subs you know tax rebates
and all that other stuff to encourage
over ten years and I think it's pretty
unconscionable at something like that
ninety ten issue after something like
this hasn't been passed I think on trade
it's the same thing this is a broader
question of so much of what we have it's
not just China I mean that's an
overwhelming thing in our trading
relationship but it's like a great
nation makes things for itself there's a
great essay I write it was like make
America autarkic again and autarky is
like making everything here I'm not
saying that's you know all the
libertarians are gonna get very upset
about me and start sending me some
comparative advantage memes but like
look there is a real benefit to be able
to make things in America and that if
just because it's cheaper the the alter
of globalization the alter of cheap
prices has made us make horrific
political choices over the last four
decades and going on that and praying
towards that altar has made it so that
we are less safe less and less robust
less I mean socially you know the to to
live in a town and to have a factory
which is producing something and to feel
pride in your work and get paid a good
wage and to know that at the explicit
decision of Congress in order to let
China to join the W or China or joining
the WTO restoring to a permanent norming
relationship permanent normal trade
relationship with China and
watching that factory go away like this
you know why that went away and people
made that choice because they said [ __ ]
you you're better off you have a cheaper
TV they said not better GDP will go up
GDP control and it did and it was great
for a few people I think that you have
to acknowledge that there's like a
deeper rot in the society where the
fundamental promise has been like if you
have cheaper stuff and you can buy more
like cheap Chinese crap you're gonna be
happy right that's gonna be the key to
happiness and so everything has been
used to justify those ends and it hasn't
made us happy it hasn't made us
satisfied it hasn't brought us any sort
of spiritual nourishment or community
and community is something that we have
completely sort of dismissed with and
despatched with and devalued in the
country as well so some of this is not
like easy here's a law you can pass and
you're good to go but I think it does
start with this fundamental idea which
comes back to kind of the core of our
show that human beings are worthy that
they have dignity that they have rights
that should be secured and if you can
take that kind of FDR economic rights
model and actually implement it into
place where people feel that they are
valued and seen and heard and have
agency and power in the society then you
are not going to have to call in the
military to American cities you're not
going to end up with a situation like we
see right now
that's spiraling and spiraling and
spiraling out of control that's another
thing you know in terms of what I would
do it's like we have to we have to
reorient our economic life and our
economic policies in order to
incentivize the building of communities
and the building of institutions that
exist outside of just the outside of
just a direct check from the government
or direct check from your work force
it's each needs to be about I mean the
way that America was like the probably
most United we ever were was around like
in the 1969 Oh everyone's going there
were terrible things had happened they
were exposed in the civil rights era and
all that but you know broadly what was
it it was like unions it was about
higher wages and it was about the
strength of the American family
and that's something that I mean every
data we see Louis marriage rate on
record in 2018 because and what's the
number one reason that people cited not
being able to get married I think so I
think it's not no man people still want
to get married it's just that they can't
afford to marriage is not sure I think
we need economic life in order to
bolster the American family and this
this this is something very much part of
like the new right movement there's this
new organization called American Compass
run by a friend of mine Oren cast he
used to work for Mitt Romney and now
what he's trying to do is a you know
move the GOP on these issues towards
centering economic like restoring like
economic conservatism from economic
libertarianism and what I mean by that
is free market fundamentalists that the
free market is always good look like the
free market was it is it a good thing
once again that we couldn't make
ventilators in our country when we
thought we needed them like was it a
good thing that we couldn't manufacture
our own medical supplies and then
broadly like in terms of the immediacy
what I would do it's this payroll plan
it's so critical that we restore
Americans payroll and that we try to
make it so that these businesses don't
become failed distressed assets that get
rolled up into these huge private equity
conglomerates that buy them all off for
cheap that [ __ ] over workers it [ __ ]
businesses and it just makes and this do
you want to live in a highly in a world
where there's no mom-and-pop businesses
or no dive bars anymore that's where
we're headed right I think two people
will put up with a lot of [ __ ] and they
will persist and they will invest in a
communal invest in their lives they'll
invest in productive civil society if
they feel that they have they they
believe that life will get better for
themselves and their kids and I really
think that's kind of the core breakdown
is that people no longer have that
confidence that for their kids it's
gonna they're going to be able to have
it better than they had and when you
lose that sense of hope that's when
things go off the rails
[Applause]